there is alarming evidence the corona
virus pandemic may be on the rise even
in parts of the country spared the worst
of this crisis until now at least 19
states 19 have seen an increase in daily
new cases over the past two weeks
several states are reporting record
spikes including South Carolina Florida
and Arizona nothing this comes amid
efforts to reopen businesses to help
ease some of the economic impact of the
pandemic Carter Evans is in Phoenix
Carter could these new numbers derail
those reopening plans in Arizona
well good morning Anthony not now at
least that's the plan Arizona's governor
admitted the rate of infection is going
the wrong direction about 11% of tests
reported on Thursday came back positive
still the governor says stay at home
orders are not under consideration we
put the stay at home order there so we
could prepare for what we are going
through right now Arizona Governor Doug
Ducey said Thursday that despite the
surge in Nuuk ovid 19 cases his state is
not in a worst-case scenario I agree
with him we're okay right now today
today what I'm concerned about is three
weeks from now
former Arizona State Health Director
will humble says some aren't taking the
risks seriously as they come out of
lockdown he says without more mitigation
like mandatory masks and more testing at
nursing homes the state's health system
could be overwhelmed I'm not talking
about another stay at home order right
now I'm talking about some interventions
that are on the table that we're not
using you sound frustrated well it's
like when you're looking at a disaster
in slow motion how can you not be
frustrated Arizona is one of at least 14
states where current hospitalizations
have increased since Memorial Day in
Arkansas hospitalizations have risen
more than 88 percent during the same
period governor ASA Hutchinson says the
state will move ahead with phase two of
its reopening plan Monday regardless of
what we see in the next week
the right decision to go ahead and lift
some of these restrictions meanwhile
there's new hope for some of the most
critically ill patients this is a
milestone doctors at Northwestern
Medicine in Chicago successfully
performed the first double lung
transplant on a Cova 19 patient in the
u.s. a young woman in her 20s with no
underlying conditions this is a healthy
lung and this is what Kovac 19 did to
hers dr. Anne KITT barad performed the
operation I hope that this you know
becomes more common because I truly
believe that we can save several
patients now president Trump is expected
to hold a rally here in Arizona on June
23rd but for next week the folks
attending his rally in Oklahoma are
being told they have to acknowledge the
wrist of a infection and the fact that
they won't hold the campaign responsible
if they get sick Flatt Carter Evans for
us this morning Carter thank you very
much